bonjour al ahly mairie oui bonjour
olivier le temps vous est le tout
dernier candidat de nous peuple
officialisé pour les législatives de
juin prochain être candidat sur fort de
france à nani mairie en compagnie de
jérémy ferdinand dans le sud de marcelin
nadeau dans l'honneur et de gérard al
mansi dans le centre atlantique pourquoi
cela at il été plus compliqué de
désigner le candidat sur fort de france
non je ne pense pas que ça a été plus
compliqué c'est à dieu que vous vous
savez que ne peut placer un mouvement
qui prône la démocratie à la base et
donc à partir du moment qu'il y a des
discussions qu'il y a des échanges il
faut laisser le temps pour que les
hommes et les femmes se décide et
fassent valoir leur point de vue et donc
il ne s'agit pas d'une organisation où
il y a un but aux politiques qui
décident donc c'est une organisation
constituée de section donc qui sont des
organes de discussion des charges et
donc lorsque les sections près de leur
décision ils font remonter leurs
décisions et donc qui sont pour la
plupart validée en assemblée générale et
donc voilà un petit peu les raisons pour
lesquelles bon fond du débat et de la
nécessité de des changes qui lie à dans
les différentes sections
ben que vous avez marre et la grinta
entre les hommes et les femmes de ce
mouvement se pose la question de la
parité
prenez par nos plats or il n'ya aucune
candidate chez vous ben oui mais vous
l'avez dit comment prôner la démocratie
directe dans un scrutin uninominal et
puis obligé un homme ou une femme à se
présenter contre son gré au contre la la
la la la volonté des médecins pas
d'équipé de candidats quand il y avait
deux sections où des femmes étaient
pressenti et elles n'ont pas n'ont pas
voulu et l'on ne pas voulu elles n'ont
pas souhaité y et ne pouvaient pas elle
est en impossibilité et puis il ya eu
d'autres sections où il y a eu des
femmes et des hommes qui ont désigné
leurs représentants sur la base de leur
présence sur le terrain de leur
militantisme de la parité surexposition
des femmes on en parle on en parle et
puis au final non j'ai pas qu'on en
parle et au final il y à il ya une
volonté de nos peuples a justement de
tenir compte de la position des femmes
en politique et donc de l'émergence des
femmes mais une volonté ne suffit pas il
faut également la détermination de ces
deux femmes pour pouvoir occuper de vous
leur dites à ces femmes qui composent
notre mouvement
formez vous préparez vous à y aller en
méforme on nous formons nous passons pas
formés vous mais formons nous passionne
au constituant une goupe une structure
est donc une organisation et donc nous
pensons qu'il s'agit pas d'une démarche
individuelle mais d'une démarche
collective et c'est ce à quoi nous
allons contribuer justement de parler
les débats les discussions qui
traversent notre organisation à mettre
en place les dispositions l'enfance et
les dispositions qui permettent qu'il y
ait beaucoup plus de femmes qui osent et
se présenter et je vais vous dire je
vais vous dire que bon c'est tellement
voilà la nécessité pour la femme de
dettes des taux aux avant-postes aux
devants en ce qui concerne les postes
électifs comme colin dit parce que elles
sont quand même présents dans toute la
vie sociale économique et de notre pays
c'est que même dans d'autres
organisations où il ya des femmes on
trouve souvent souvent un bain les mêmes
femmes qui skient soit qu'ils soient au
devant de la scène
cela cela suppose qu'il y ait quand même
une carence en termes de formation en
termes de volonté en termes de dynamisme
et donc aussi la question de la
confiance en soi pour pouvoir être
devant de la scène très bien vous allez
sur cette circonscription de fort de
france fief du sortant serge chimie dont
la priorité quand même de repartir à la
conquête de sa base et de mieux rebondir
sur l'ensemble de l'île on parle de
serge letchimy battu lors des élections
de la 7e et puis l'autre candidat 3,6
carroll dont l'ambition de faire tomber
le ppm et c'est avec ses alliés du mime
cette bataille letchimy carole va-t-elle
occulter tout le reste selon vous dans
cette circonscription je ne sais pas
monsieur le temps parce que nous ne
sommes pas je ne suis pas venu ici pour
faire l'arbitrage entouré d'autres
rendre le candidat dont le peuple a et
les autres candidats nous sommes venus
pour afficher notre point de vue faire
valoir les idées que nous avons
défendues depuis la création de notre
organisation être au coeur de la
préoccupation des femmes et des hommes
de notre pays et donc c'est le sens de
vous allez proposer autre chose que ce
bruit entre carole et chimie vous allez
faire quoi exactement
je ne dirais pas qu'il s'agit de bruit
parce que nous avons pour principe de
respecter l'ensemble des martiniquais et
donc mais il s'agit d'idées et de
construction d'une démarche alternative
différente qui sort de ce que nous
voyons habituellement et donc qu'est ce
que vous voyez sur fort de france et qui
vous déplaît que vous aimeriez changer
en tant que député de cette
circonscription
mais je suis particulièrement préoccupé
par tout ce qui concerne mon à situation
de la jeunesse dans notre pays par tout
ce qui concerne la question de la santé
et quand on voit que si je prends je
fais référence au quartier beauregard
donc que j'habite ben je peux vous dire
que quand nous sommes encerclés avec
toute une série d'entreprises et dont
nous avons aussi compris occupation à
nous peuple à la question de l'écologie
la question de la santé et que nous
voyons que tout fort de france est
cernée par un certain nombre de
structures qui dégage des dd qui tient
des activités polluantes
certes qui sont qui sont des acteurs
économiques des vecteurs économique et
que nous nous trouvons sur le fond de la
nécessité d'adresser des poèmes de santé
des besoins d'éducation des poèmes
d'écologie des problèmes de souveraineté
alimentaire
nous sommes donné une occupation il faut
de fonction des préoccupations portées
par exemple par le candidat sortant
serge letchimy il peut les porter mais
nous nous considérons qu'il s'agit de
construire des alternatives aussi
l'époque je crois que le gouvernement
français
en tous les cas valls qui l'a soutenu
n'a pas porté ses revendications pendant
toutes sa mandature donc tout ces
éléments et satisfaction à ses
revendications on a tous sa mandature al
donc il peut les porter mais nous ne les
mettons en oeuvre
qu'est ce que vous allez faire pour
porter votre message ce sera le
traditionnel porte à porte des prises de
paroles commencé faire campagne vous
notre campagne a commencé depuis bien
longtemps puisque vous avez vu que
lorsque je vous ai parlé des
préoccupations en matière de santé en
matière d'écologie ou d'un rêve une opep
la prison sur le terrain aux côtés de la
socam ans dans l'art dans le cadre de
l'action contre l'implantation d'al
biomasse et nous pensons qu'il faut une
mobilisation beaucoup plus importante
vous savez qu'il ya une vague de fond
sur la guadeloupe
i'll be home a été également pointé du
doigt et donc sinon nous nous revenons
en arrière et novices nous voyons un
petit peu ce qui s'est passé avec la
question du chlordécone
comment aujourd'hui faire fi de des
dangers que représente l'installation
dans le bios maïs ou le blé biologique
et donc sur le plan de la santé
nous avons des martiniquais également
qu'ils réfléchissent constitution
d'inspiration toutes ces raisons d'être
inquiet verser je voudrais vous dire par
exemple si vous lisez ce que monsieur
charles le docteur charles on dit ah
bein sûr là où groupe la quintessence de
l'ensemble des actions qu'il faudrait
conduire sur le plan de l'environnement
sur le plan de la souveraineté
alimentaire sous le plan de la santé
eh ben on parle des atouts que possède
la matinée sous le nom de sa
biodiversité c'est mettre en évidence en
mode action
l'ensemble de ces leviers pour que nous
puissions sortir de ce marasme
économique dont tout le monde savait que
nous allons nous orienter
depuis des lustres et ces thèmes seront
suffisants pour mobiles
et lorsqu'on voit par exemple que
d'autres thèmes d'autres façons de mener
campagne d'autres élections
mais ça semble jeter le discrédit sur
toute la classe politique dans son
ensemble on parle de la présidentielle
notamment la présidentielle membres
vous savez nous avons donné nous avons
de vue sur la question des
présidentielles maintenant le tapage
ce n'est pas notre préoccupation parce
que ça ne date pas d'aujourd'hui ce
genre de tapage
c'est monsieur fillon aujourd'hui
c'était monsieur juppé avant hier
c'était monsieur hollande sur d'autres
aspects et donc nous les connaissons
tous et c'est pour ça que nous rejetons
cette classe politique depuis des années
et c'est le sens de l'implication de nos
plats de cette campagne c'est aussi une
autre manière de concevoir la politique
c'est une manière d'être à l'écouté de
notre population mais également de notre
diaspora à qui nous allons justement
dans ce brouillard le col collon qu'on
leur présente avec monsieur fillon de
prendre de faire bien attention et donc
de ne pas non plus tomber dans le
travers de l'alternance politique en
faisant le choix éventuellement d'une
extrême droite dont on connaît les
les dégâts occasionnés dans le monde et
dans l'histoire où se les mairies
reprenez votre façon de vouloir faire la
politique avec nos plats depuis la
campagne pour les élections de la ctm
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
cette mayonnaise la prends vraiment est
ce que cette façon de de concevoir la
politique séduit de plus en plus haut
mais elle séduit c'est le nous sommes
une organisation que nous qualifions
l'organisation citoyenne
donc nous ne nous ne cultive pas qu'il y
à des militants de différentes
organisations mais qui sont inscrits de
manière individuelle dans cette
organisation que nous peuple a annoncé
que nous portons un message et vous avez
vu nos scores réalisés lors des
élections à la cité m nous avons
également fustigé le fait qu'il n'y ait
pas une élection qui soit basée sur la
proportionnelle intégrale ce qui
permettrait l'expression des différents
courants et notamment de nos peuples a
dans l'espace politique entière
deux visions décisionnel et donc non
nous nous pensons que la configuration
et le grand mouvement qui prennent forme
dans le monde pas uniquement martin dans
le monde vous avez vu comment en
roumanie
l attaque contre la corruption et il
vient matraqué et donc nous avons de
plus en plus confiance en la nécessité
d'avoir un impôt est un langage nouveau
mais une pratique nouvelle sur le plan
politique en martinique merci d'avoir
été avec toi lahlimi rappelle que vous
êtes candidat de nos plats dans la
circonscription de fort de france merci
d'avoir été dans certaines régions le
temps
[Musique]